So now, you're almost at
the end of your program.
And this is also the system that you'll
be using to apply for graduation.
Click Student Services and
Financial Aid.
Then click Student Records.
Next, click Apply to Graduate.
Select the term in which
you want to graduate.
And from here, follow the prompts.
After, you can view your
application to graduate as well.
>> Typically, you should apply to
graduate the term before you want to
graduate.
So, if you want to graduate in spring,
you should apply to
graduate the previous fall.
If it turns out you don't
complete the classes necessary,
that's all right,
you can always postpone graduation.
But you need to have applied by
the end of the semester before.
Check the registrar's website for
specific application deadlines.